[Musica]
Eccoci
Sono venuto a parlarvi di acqua che è un
tema Un tema che non è personale se non
per il fatto che il mio babbo era un
idraulico ma voglio dire non è una cosa
così particolarmente interessante sono
venuto a parlare di acqua che non è un
tema personale Un tema che riguarda
tutti qualcosa abbiamo sentito già
adesso da Andrea Gori è un tema che
riguarda tutti in Italia di solito
quando le cose riguardano tutti sembra
quasi che non siam di nessuno no cioè le
cose pubbliche non sono di nessuno in
realtà riguarda ognuno di noi per cui
sentitevi coinvolti Come direbbe De
Gregori Anche perché viviamo sul pianeta
dell'acqua questa fotografia che è stata
chiamata da Bloom Marble è stata
scattata il 7 dicembre del 1972
dall'equipaggio dell'Apollo 17 l'ultimo
equipaggio andato sulla luna ed è una
fotografia famosissima perché forse
l'unica una delle pochissime in cui si
vede completamente la terra illuminata
dalla luce del sole No tutto questo lato
è tutto quanto illuminato dalla luce del
sole un pianeta coperto d'acqua tenete
coperto d'acqua possibile io il gioco
del possibile impossibile me lo son
giocato così è possibile che abbiamo dei
problemi con l'acqua
è possibile chiedete la signorina la
signora Francesca Francisca chagas che
una signora brasiliana che vive a Rio
Bravo nello Stato della Cri dove nel
2015 c'è stata un'alluvione che ha
allagato anche la casa fino all'altezza
Duomo lei tranquillamente lì si fuma la
sigaretta qualcun altro come spesso ci
succede ha pensato di affidarsi alla
provvidenza No in realtà l'acqua è un
problema c'è chi ne ha troppa come come
in alcuni casi con inondazioni
memorabili come queste dello Stato della
critica in uno degli Stati amazzonici e
c'è chi ne ha troppa anche non solo
perché arriva dall'alto con la pioggia
perché gli arriva dal basso perché qui
poi parleremo un pochino il cambiamento
climatico Questi sono gli abitanti di
kiribati che è uno degli Stati più
minacciati dall'aumento del livello dei
Mari con il cambiamento climatico Qui
stanno cercando di aumentare gli argini
perché l'acqua durante le mareggiate non
entri e non distrugga le strade
e poi c'è anche chi ne ha troppo poca
qui siamo Ken nel 2022
uno dei periodi nei periodi di siccità
più straordinari che ci siano stati
nell'africa orientale sono almeno dieci
anni forse qualcosa di più che
alternatamente ci sono dei periodi
siccità tremendi che per popolazione che
vivono essenzialmente di allevamento
nomade o di agricoltura di sussistenza
sono un problema fondamentale uno dice
vabbè in Africa La siccità poi si trova
davanti questa foto qui in Africa sto
terreno Qua ci sta raccontando una cosa
che sappiamo già questa è una foto del
Galles 11 agosto 2022 nel piovoso Regno
Unito la piovosa Gran Bretagna esiste A
Londra piove sempre Ecco il Galles l'11
agosto dell'anno scorso era messo in
queste condizioni per cui non è più solo
una questione di siccità
desertificazione africana o al massimo
delle zone più meridionali dell'Europa
ma cominciano ad esserci problemi di
acqua anche in zone che storicamente
sono estremamente piovose anche la
prossima questa è un'altra zona piovosa
e questo è quello che sembra
un fiume stagionale in mezzo in mezzo a
Sahara in realtà questa è una foto della
Loira sempre nell'agosto dell'anno
scorso uno i grandi fiumi Europei famosa
per i suoi meravigliosi castelli che
erano completamente asciutto l'anno
scorso L'estate del 2022 è stata una
delle stati più calde Seguita a un
periodo anche estremamente poco piovoso
che ha portato a una carenza d'acqua in
tutta Europa lo sappiamo benissimo anche
in Italia perché il poi è stato il
minimi storici tutte le forme di acqua
cominciano a scarseggiare su questo
pianeta perché in realtà Queste sono le
piste da sci tedesche nel gennaio di
quest'anno io non so che gusto ci si
trovi ad andare a sciare in un posto del
genere perché in realtà si va a fare una
passeggiata e forse cercare funghi però
il punto è che per avere la neve
quest'anno Ma già l'anno scorso sempre
di più negli anni a venire l'idea sarà
quella di prendere acqua a prelevare
acqua
e ricongelarla e spararla sulle piste da
sci tutto questo per farci divertire con
un enorme spreco e di acqua e di energia
il problema qual è che tutta quest'acqua
che vediamo
questo pianeta meraviglioso che di fatto
è come dire il singolo composto
principale che ha dato che ha dato
origine alla vita sulla terra c'è acqua
in tutti i nostri corpi ci sono
addirittura essere viventi che hanno
sono composti più del 90% da acqua è il
singolo come dire singolo composto che
ci ha permesso di sviluppare la civiltà
le grandi civiltà sono nate sull'acqua
penso alla civiltà dell'indo in India
alla civiltà egizia che è nata sul Nilo
e che è tutto sommato la madre di tutte
le civiltà poi
dell'Europa e dell'Occidente Penso al
fatto che di fatto tutte le grandi città
le importanti città sono nate sull'acqua
Il problema è che quest'acqua non è poi
così tanta se voi Guardate là sopra
questa qua è tutta l'acqua che c'è sulla
terra perché sembra così poca Questa è
una bellissima rappresentazione Secondo
me la più immediata in assoluto dello
iOS GS americano e così poca perché in
realtà la terra è una boccia di 6.300 km
di diametro e gli oceani Per quanto la
ricoprono per tre quarti sono spessi 3
km e mezzo per cui se uno mette tutto il
volume dell'acqua degli oceani in un
punto è quello là ma c'è di peggio
il pallino più grande questo qui
rappresenta tutta l'acqua che c'è sul
pianeta il secondo pallino rappresenta
tutta l'acqua dolce e il terzo questo
affare qua che non si vedeva neanche
nell'immagine precedente e l'acqua del
fiume dei Laghi
se uno vuole andare a vederla con più
con più dettaglio tutta l'acqua 96%
dell'acqua che c'è sul pianeta più
l'acqua salata quella dei grandi laghi
salati Come il Mar Caspio e il 97,5
quindi l'acqua dolce è solo il 2,5%,
fatto 100 Quello
609% praticamente due terzi poco più di
due terzi sono nelle calotte glaciali e
nei ghiacciai il 30% è acqua sotterranea
l'acqua superficiale è 1,2% dell'acqua
dolce sostanzialmente oltretutto tutta
quell'acqua è terreni ghiacciate
permafrost in gran parte e la parte di
laghi e fiumi È pochissimo quindi Sì
l'acqua dei Laghi dei fiumi che è quella
sostanzialmente su cui si basa la vita
sulla terra quella di cui abbiamo
bisogno noi
e quella di cui hanno bisogno le specie
animali è pochissima su questo pianeta
pochissima e si ricicla attraverso il
ciclo il ciclo meteorologico
dell'evaporazione della traspirazione e
della pioggia però è pochina quindi sì
abbiamo dei problemi con l'acqua abbiamo
dei problemi anche con quella che è di
più con quella salata li vediamo di
corsa perché non c'è il tempo per
parlare si potrebbe parlarne per ore
però il primo il problema è il
cambiamento climatico questo è
un'immagine del marzo 2020
della della Noah che l'amministrazione
che si occupa degli oceani negli Stati
Uniti e che fa vedere come le
temperature superficiali fossero più
alte quasi ovunque sul pianeta rispetto
alla media non la media degli anni per
industriali eccetera la media del 1982
2010 in termini geologici l'altro ieri
quel problema del cambiamento climatico
di riscaldamento che cosa abbiamo un
aumento del livello dei Mari con anche
un aumento che dovuto due cose
lo scioglimento delle calotte glaciali
da una parte soprattutto Antartide e
Groenlandia dall'altra la dilatazione
termica dell'acqua e qui non andiamo a
complicarci la vita più di tanto poi
abbiamo una proliferazione di specie
invasive perché probabilmente lo sapete
nel Mediterraneo sono arrivate specie
che non ci sono mai state a Venezia ci
sono i granchi blu che sono tipicamente
tipicamente tropicali lacidificazione ha
effetti sugli animali con l'esoscheletro
calcareo sono stati fatti studi sulle
vongole e insomma le vongole Ci teniamo
tutti quanti per una ragione per l'altra
più per l'altra in realtà non è tanto la
salute delle vongole che ci sta a cuore
e sono stati fatti degli Studi per cui
il guscio calcare delle vongole si sta
leggermente assottigliando con con la
cedificazione dei mari in più lo
sbiancamento e la morte del barriere
coralline come questa meraviglia nelle
abitudine che portano sostanzialmente
alla perdita di quello che un patrimonio
straordinario di questo pianeta che
altro abbiamo abbiamo l'inquinamento ci
sono c'è un arcipelago di plastica ormai
non c'è più un'isola sono almeno cinque
le grandi le grandi isole della plastica
a livello globale perché ogni anno ci
sono 8 milioni di tonnellate di plastica
che finiscono negli oceani
tendenzialmente ci finiscono arrivando
dai fiumi e perlopiù da fiumi asiatici e
dell'America Latina e dell'Africa
l'altro problema che abbiamo con l'acqua
salata un altro le grandi problemi e la
pesca La pesca è quadruplicata nell'arco
di 50 anni in realtà abbiamo ridotto del
70% quella che è la popolazione di quasi
tutte le specie commerciali alcune
addirittura si dice il 90%, questo è
un'immagine del mercato del pesce di
Tokyo quando c'era ancora questo
meraviglioso luogo che era il mercato di
tsukiji e questi sono i tonni scaricati
da una sola nave nell'arco di una
giornata questo mercato Era un mercato
talmente
imponente e ci passava il 20% del
pescato mondiale ogni giorno
detto questo passiamo all'acqua dolce
l'acqua dolce Questa è un'immagine
l'avete già vista prima nelle immagini
di Andrea Gori e il Pakistan 2022 siamo
in agosto
c'è da dire che questa inondazione è
stata talmente enorme da provocare quasi
2000 vittime 30.000 km di strade
distrutte 30 milioni di persone
coinvolte perché se uno dice 85.000 km
quadrati di inondazione Sì 85.000 km
quadrati sono Piemonte Lombardia Emilia
Romagna e Veneto così fate un'idea su
una cartina geografica dell'Italia Quale
può essere stata l'aria allagata il
primo indiziato è il cambiamento
climatico sorvolo su quelli che sono i
dettagli di questa parte però l'ultimo
rapporto della ipcc quello del febbraio
2022 il penultimo ormai ci ha detto che
c'è tutta una serie di problemi legati
al cambiamento climatico e che sono
legati all'Acqua e soprattutto che danno
in sicurezza idrica a molte popolazioni
vediamo che di che cosa si tratta
Noi abbiamo acqua potabile che manca a 2
miliardi di persone 2,2 Per la
precisione nel mondo Abbiamo quasi due
miliardi di persone che dipendono
servizi e strutture sanitarie che non
hanno non hanno acqua servizi idrici di
base Che cosa vuol dire che ci sono
ospedali luoghi di primo soccorso in
mezzo mondo dove tu vai ma non c'è acqua
pulita
quasi 300 mila bambini sotto i 5 anni
muoiono ogni anno di dissenteria dovuta
a carenze igienico sanitarie per l'acqua
e oltretutto l'80% delle acque reflue
che rispediamo in mare e negli oceani
normalmente non è trattato altri
problemi come la usiamo l'acqua l'acqua
la usiamo quasi tutta essenzialmente nel
mondo per l'agricoltura
in Europa occidentale cioè dalle nostre
parti il 75% dell'acqua usata per
agricoltura allevamento in altre parti
del mondo anche di più globalmente
consumo dell'acqua è quasi per l'85%
dovuto all'agricoltura che serve per dar
da mangiare a noi e agli animali
dell'allevamento ma il modo in cui la
usiamo è strettamente legato anche al
modo in cui abbiamo deviato i corsi
d'acqua nel mondo Oggi ci sono 54 mila
dighe 54 mila più alte di 15 metri sono
quelle sono considerate le grandi dighe
poi ci sono quelle piccole sono
soprattutto usate per deviare acque per
la canalizzazione per l'irrigazione ma
anche per produrre energia idroelettrica
tutto questo che cosa porta porta
un'instabilità generale per cui l'acqua
è diventata un fattore di attrito
geopolitico un fattore di attrito
geopolitico in alcune particolari
regioni del mondo lo è in questa zona
qua cioè tra il Sudan l'Egitto e
l'uganda dove si sudano informato
diverse dighe sul Nilo che potrebbero
assettare parlavamo prima di civiltà
nate nate sull'acqua potrebbero
assettare proprio l'Egitto che a Valle
del Sudan dal punto di vista del fluire
del fiume Questo è un grande problema di
acqua perché ci sono le acque
dell'indole e il gancio del bravo putra
che sono quelle che portano
essenzialmente acqua a 140 milioni di
Agricoltori indiani e però uno si
stupisce quando Guarda quassù E dice ma
che attrito ci potrebbe essere nel
midwest degli Stati Uniti che l'acqua
che ci arriva la usiamo talmente male
l'acqua che ci piove dal cielo che ormai
per quelle che sono le attività umane
soprattutto l'agricoltura finiamo per
sfruttare l'acqua di falda Che cos'è
l'acqua di falda è quella che sta sotto
terra la più grande falda acquifera
degli Stati Uniti che si chiama ogallala
con un nome relativi americani viene
svuotata a un livello da 10 metri
all'anno il che significa che nel giro
di pochi anni quello che è il
Granaio d'America Il Granaio poi loro
fanno più maschi che grano In realtà
quello che è Il Granaio d'America
potrebbe non avere più l'acqua per
l'irrigazione allora
è un pianeta fatto d'acqua pianeta fatto
d'acqua da usare con una certa
parsimonia nel racconto di Andrea Gori
avete sentito che gli strumenti ci sono
e li abbiamo per cercare di raggiungere
quelli che sono considerati gli
obiettivi di sviluppo sostenibile da
parte delle Nazioni Unite Qual è il
destino finale della situazione adesso
poi voglio vedere quante sono le maniche
si alzano se vi chiedo se siete
ottimisti perché in realtà possiamo
essere ottimisti Questa è una copertina
che noi abbiamo pubblicato tre anni fa
in aprile 2020 e per i 50 anni della
giornata della terra la versione di
destra cioè quella che che vedete dritta
per il momento era abbiamo salvato il
pianeta perché abbiamo ancora una scelta
per cercare di limitare il nostro
impatto sulle risorse in generale E
sull'acqua in particolare poi potremmo
invece continuare business future
perderlo il pianeta che non significa la
fine della vita sulla terra e forse
neanche la fine dell'uomo ma magari un
peggioramento drastico del nostro
benessere e questo lo possiamo fare
semplicemente Se continuiamo a
comportarci nei confronti delle risorse
come se fossero infinite come
potrebbe raccontarci una vignetta di
Mauro biani che apparsi su Repubblica un
po' di tempo fa e che secondo me è la
peggiore soluzione possibile ma che
possiamo ancora evitare Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]